I'd like to introduce some terminologies that we can talk more easily about the
different quantities we're dealing with. We'll call the amount of money that
Grant initially invested in the account, the principal, which in Grant's case
is $10,000. We also already mentioned the interest rate before. And in Grant's
case, this is 3%. Now, let's think back to the math that we were doing. In the
expression, 10,000 times 1 plus 0.03. Where do the numbers 10,000 and 0.03 come
from? For each one, please pick one of these choices. The number of years the
money is invested, the number of times interest is compounded per year, the
interest rate as a percentage per year, the interest rate as a decimal per
year, the principal or the number of months in a year.